bien joli visage que celui de madame la
présidente je ne sais pas anthony quinn
si vous avez l'occasion de regarder la
télévision
il avait le temps de la regarder nous
avons de tels examens et halima c'est
pas bon il faut dire que ses parents la
télévision d'état les maintenant
définies sont jolies oui mais pas tous
les membres se soient pas sous le menton
est allé les speakerines les speakerines
vous trouvez qu elles sont bien choisis
d'habitude puis je prends soin d'étaler
ce c'est la seule chose de lagardère
dans la télévision les principales
programme asie vous même l'udaf de time
to do to make television shows y en a
marre et le temps de faire des shows de
télévision partout non pas l'état des
j'ai fait des télévisions et en amérique
mon pain est allé on n'aime pas on n'y
est pourtant maintenant avec votre
disque il va bien falloir chanter à la
télévision j'ai jean pagé pâle dans les
déchets du chanteur pourquoi vous n'avez
pas voulu aller jusqu'aux nations
j'aime palais dans l'eu10 marchand pêche
j'ai su par frank sinatra mais je les
fais ce jeu vous propose avant de
continuer cette conversation d'écouté
quand même quelques mesures
c'est comme ça
c'est à 14 l'ancien rennais qui est
ressorti des données
la vexation jours la dame a tous les
soleils avait sa liseuse c'est fini je
sais ce que tout pouvait penser à
l'américain ce que les trois semaines de
se pendre avec la jolie dans le parc
les problèmes ce que ce tout nouveau pas
revivre
je vis maintenant c'est pas la camair
les soleils et à me cacher la camargue
vous connaissez les icônes bien j'ai
fait six mois la camargue je vais les
vies des vagues hors jeu fait de google
à berne
mais si ça me plaît beaucoup la camargue
c'est un peu comme le mexique nous y
fait d'un bug cheval oui ça me plaît
beaucoup j'ai fait beaucoup de western
où ça nous gêne le cheval lui avait fait
des westerns et est ce que l'on peut
dire c'est qu'à chaque fois que vous
avez fait un film dans lequel vous
faisiez autre chose que simplement un
travail d'acteur va essayer de faire des
exploits qu'il s'agissait de mettre dans
un climat vous faisiez l'effort d'aller
d'aller travailler par exemple pour orba
le grec devait passer assez longtemps en
grèce pour vous et climat t au petit
bistrot et ya ceux qui malades
et oui ça me plaît beaucoup le glas
d'une grande propreté la page
et puis thil il se dit grèce gg devenu
presque les pousse le film zorba mais
chaque fois que j'ai fait j'ai fait mon
film je prends je devienne italien
lettres mexicaines
ça c'est la seule chose que ma muse de
fait le comédien mexicain n'ai pas
besoin de beaucoup de temps en temps
j'ai oublié le mexique non non non pas
du tout pas du tout j'ai mexique avec
moi toujours pas oublié le muc six roads
vous aviez un grand projet arrivait orba
en particulier de créer un centre
philosophique
oui c'est une chose que je voudrais
faire parce que je pense qu'il n'y a pas
un on doit maintenant pour tous les gens
que je voudrais avec ton mec à sainté
d'être explorée centre qui va passer
dans dans les futures de le devenir
tous les scientifiques les deux sweep
1,30 ou les îles aux à tous les
créateurs finale se rassembleraient pour
étudier l'avenir non pas seulement parce
que l'avenir m'intéresse mais parce que
j'ai beaucoup d'enfants et je voudrais
bien savoir ce la vie qu'ils vont les
besoins de sa tâche ce stade il y à une
telle initiative serait prise par neuf
une personnalité américaine mais qui n'a
à bouzy nulle part je crois c'est fait
compte tenu de la situation géographique
des droitsde que cette audience a des
chances un désir mais moi ce que rodez
merveilleusement situé à cet égard tu
peux à mi chemin la frieze au wat
d'israël c'est vraiment le point
cardinal ou non pourrait créer il
passera le moyen-orient on sera
déterminant pour notre vie dans les
cinquante années à venir
mais c'est intéressant de vous entendre
dire ça car on a souvent l'impression
que les acteurs de cinéma de théâtre se
détache un petit peu de la vie du monde
ils vivent pour eux mêmes non je ne
pense pas du tout que ce soit vrai ces
acteurs vivent parfaitement leur temps
je crois d'ailleurs que c'est un petit
peu mais connaître leur rôle les acteurs
doivent véritablement jouer un rôle
d'avant-garde dans l'histoire et dans la
vie et personnellement je suis très
soucieux de ce qui se passe dans le
tailleur ça fait partie de notre rôle
on a dit à certains moments que les
acteurs ne se ne devrait jamais
s'engager politiquement religieusement
philosophiquement non ce n'est pas du
tout vrai il faut regarder les choses en
face et être mûr dans ce domaine
carter ont le droit de s'exprimer et
doivent le faire vous lisez toujours
beaucoup vous même parce que vous étiez
l'un de ceux dans le monde du spectacle
qui lisait beaucoup qu'ils allaient
beaucoup au concert vous aimez la
musique
vous avez une vocation d'architecte au
départ mouillée être architecte
architecte
j'ai haï stade inouï de grévistes chez
j'ai étudié auprès de francs quadra est
l'un des plus grands architectes eux
mondiaux et je suis passé au cinéma
simplement pour gagner suffisamment
d'argent pour retourner à l'école mais
je finalement je me suis resté dans le
cinéma c'est la vie mais j'ai je
conserve un très grand enthousiasme pour
le architecture et c'est peut-être un
peu ce qui m'a amené à choisir roth
parce que je voulais créer mon propre
site architectural quelque sorte mais
aussi toucher au théâtre vous me
demandez si je jouais en fait j'ai joué
dans la dernière pièce de tennessee
williams aux états unis mais
malheureusement celle-ci n'était pas
tout à fait mûr
peut-être qu'elle parlait de deux
problèmes politiques que l'amérique
n'était pas encore tout à fait prête à
attendre
il s'agissait en fait de la conspiration
autour du meurtre de kennedy et je crois
que l'amérique était pas prête à
entendre ce genre de choses
l'amérique était dans une phase de ce
réexamen global et ne souhaitait pas que
l'on annonce approfondie sur ce genre de
chose finalement
et vous aviez commencé avant de cinéma
par le théâtre les premières fois où
vous vous êtes montrés au public c'était
au théâtre petit théâtre parce que votre
père avait déjà une vocation artistique
il était caméraman non oui il était le
deuxième caméraman et d'ailleurs c'était
une période assez extraordinaire c'est
d'ailleurs je m'appelle antonio rudolph
au queen we
en fait seul homme qui m'a donné le nom
de rodolfo était rodolfo valentino et il
m'a en fait les en fait devenir mon père
adoptif et il avait une avec 9 ans à
l'époque et il m'a dit il prédit qu'un
jour je serai un acteur il ya une chose
intéressante d'ailleurs j'ai reçu il ya
deux ans le prix rudolph valentino en
italie c'est d'ailleurs amusant à temps
et bien raconter le monde est prêt c'est
amusant non en fait ce qui est
intéressant c'est 2 à 8 ans bombao dole
valentino visa il ne sera qu acteur et
non seulement il a constaté il ya eu
réseau je suis devenu un acteur
d'ailleurs je lui ressemblais un petit
peu et il m'a offert 2
offert de jouer la vie de valentino et
j'ai eu l'intelligence de refuser
d'ailleurs parce que je n'aurais pas
certainement faire une virée sûrs de le
faire mais je dois dire que je lui dois
beaucoup
cette histoire si vous voulez nenad
autre mérite que de dire que finalement
j'ai eu prerure valentino jordan
valentino qui je dois vous le dire sera
sera tourné très bientôt par ken russell
et ce sera rudolf noureev qui jouera le
rôle de hayden valentino linge tournage
commence en angleterre au mois d'août
je pense qu'il va faire un grand succès
parce qu'ils allaient même force et la
même énergie de l'ofa vingtaine à élever
mon beau je pense qu'il va fait
longuement quand on a tourné et ce sera
ma dernière question anthony quinn quand
on a tourné avec quasiment quand on a
tourné avec cécile b 2000 quand on a
tourné avec les plus grands du cinéma
avec fleischer particulier le barabbas
en 1961 et qu'on a des tas de passion
dans sa vie la lecture la musique est ce
qu'aujourd'hui on ne se dit pas bon il
est temps que je m'arrête où j'ai encore
quand même envie de faire quelque chose
non parce que toujours il ya des choses
à faire
maintenant j'ai la passion la compassion
de faire la vie de picasso pour
l'exemple et aussi je suis venu ici
justement pour faire une production que
nous sommes avec france pouvait la vie
des rebelles que ça m'intéresse beaucoup
de faits la vidéo d'annoncé la vie de
picasso parti que le monde et la vie dès
lors d'impasses qu'il avait survécu vécu
vécu dans une période très intéressante
en france la période des fêtes la
période et victor hugo et tout ça a été
je pense que que c'est cela on donne
ce film est de il ya toujours quelque
chose à fait à la loggia mais pas le
moment
merci et nous ne le souhaitons pas
surtout anthony quinn merci en tout cas
d'être venu à l'occasion de ce passage à
paris d'avoir été mon avis aujourd'hui
nous vous retrouverons par le disque si
nous ne nous met pas tous les jours à la
télévision
à très bientôt